pas assez leurs deux cultures première
avec jean-paul malade et ses invités
[Musique]
celui-ci émission un peu spéciale ce
soir et sera consacrée presque
entièrement à la sortie du cd de danyel
waro moment assez des spéciales dans ce
titre
et puis nous recevons des représentants
du collège jean des sme de set maria du
parc pour nous parler de l'air leur
dernier concours d'éloquence
j'aime pole mais l'adq culture première
sur réunion 1ère bonsoir merci à tous du
rejoint de réunion première pour cette
nouvelle édition de culture première
bonsoir à nos invités merci à vous aussi
de rester avec nous pour ces 45 minutes
d'émission berset notre technicien babu
qui nous accompagnent ce soir
trois invités dont du sexe féminin pour
commencer cette émission trois
représentants du collège jean besse mme
de set maria du parc un collège qui
porte fièrement ses 40 ans un
établissement dirigé par dominique
fruteau rasé depuis trois ans et depuis
quatre ans on y organise un concours
d'éloquence et cette année nous recevons
les gagnantes ou là leur compte et 17e
en gros qui par deux jeunes filles en
2010 7,2 et lisa et 10 à la bourde
frassati elisa marcy bourg sera toutes
les deux bon ça aulas en coeur ont plus
souvent soir dominique le fruit 3 et
rapprochez vous du micro s'il vous plaît
merci beaucoup
alors pourquoi un concours d'éloquence
un concours d'éloquence parce que il est
important que nos jeunes et les jeunes
réunionnais puissent apprendre à
s'exprimer de la façon la plus complète
possible dans nos écoles nous ne
privilégions pas suffisamment
l'expression orale donc apprendre à
parler à prendre à convaincre apprendre
à argumenter apprendre à séduire et
peut-être puisque ce concours existe
maintenant aussi dans une région
métropolitaine
apprendre à parler avec son corps son
esprit et avec ses poings donc éviter la
violence et des abus alors c'est ce
qu'on pourrait dire c'est ce qu'on
pourrait dire en région parisienne il y
à une association qui a mis en place un
concours d'éloquence dans le en seine
saint denis
est ce cette cette procédure a été
suffisamment remarquer pour que les
médias s'en emparent et que notamment
sur france
il ya eu un film documentaire sur ce
concours d'éloquence c'est très bien
pour les petites oreilles de votre pause
ita soit et d'extorsion ci s'intéresse à
la réunion mais nous n'avons pas terminé
c'est dommage ben alors justement à ce
concours de danse comment on prépare les
élèves
eh bien on les prépare de différentes
façons d'abord il ya la recherche
documentaire il faut que les élèves à y
voir
chaque année nous choisissons une valeur
cette année ça a été le estime de soi
donc les enfants vont déjà faire des
recherches documentaires
ensuite il faut qu'ils écrivent leurs
discours donc il ya toute la capacité de
l'imaginaire la capacité à l'expression
écrite et puis après il ya tout là toute
la possibilité de d'expression orale
avec la gestuelle les ça peut être au
niveau du discours ça peut être des
chants du poème et c'est cette année
comme le thème était les cimes de soi
nous avons pu faire venir un psychologue
qui a discuté avec les élèves sur ce que
c'est que l'estiment de soi et nous
allons travailler également avec etienne
andoche un comédien qui a pu les
préparer aux discours à l'oralité devant
public
alors mesdemoiselles rebond soir donc
alors comment ça se passe justement
comment ça s'est passé pour vous alors
elisa la première elisa l'isaf à lagord
face à ce type man ça s'est passé
ben en fait c'est sain c'est eh bien on
a d'abord fait des répétitions
pour avec le professeur en fait on a
fait avec la bibliothécaire et on a
travaillé aussi avec le professeur pour
la culture pour l'écriture pas trop
enfin le discours on a plutôt fait tout
seul mais avec le professeur et la
bibliothèque car madame or on a
travaillé tout ce qui était orale la
façon de s'exprimer
l'intonation de la voix et on a fait
beaucoup de répétitions et voilà bah et
les amarres si c'était difficile de vent
juste eu mans de pouvoir voir
l'intonation et ensuite connaître son
texte par coeur bat à force de réviser
on a connu au fur et à mesure et sinon
lente aux nations ben on a appris au
fait des recommandations
on veut vous posez une colle est ce
qu'aujourd'hui en sixième on fait encore
des récitations on apprend des poèmes
parker par exemple de danyel waro par
potel pourquoi pas mais où d'autres
personnes connues ou moins connues parce
qu'en général
alors maintenant c'est fini ça c'est
plus à la mode moi je conte secondes on
faisait on faisait des commandes et des
compositions what happens m'appelle plus
laver la récitation btp de météorites et
décident à leur premier prix 2ème 3ème
prix alors ça se fait plus de mini-krach
fruteau rasé s'est terminée il ya ils
arrivent de toute façon en 4e molia le
programme sur le théâtre
et lorsque les élèves travaillent sur
des pièces de théâtre il faut absolument
qu'ils apprennent des textes donc le la
poésie elle est encore en apprentissage
dans les écoles alors qu'en même temps
vous avez pris pour justement mémoriser
votre texte un mois deux mois trois mois
alors on a pris à peu près un mois et
demi le temps d'écrire de réviser et
et de bien connaître notre notre texte
par coeur donc pour cela on sait on
s'est inspiré aussi d'une chanson enfin
moi pour ma part je me suis inspirée
d'une chanson c'était à prendre de yves
duteil et est du coup bas le fait de
rechercher aussi là bas toujours plus
haut essayer de toujours perfectionner
ce confort des formules voilà laurie
lisa marcy est ce que il a fallu donc
apprendre à mémoriser mais aussi à ce
que là on a fait des des gestes de nice
l'expression du corps du visage
l'expression du corps et du visage est
venu tout seul avec le texte on a fait à
voir avec les doux et cette petite
non c'est de me dire ça répond ça comme
ça comme c'est évident non david
chassagne bon sort donc ça alors vous
qui était membre du jury c'est un hasard
d'ailleurs je ne savais pas je ne suis
tout à l'heure comment en tant que
membre du jury vous avez je n'ai
apprécié ce genre de performance n'était
pas un membre du jury cette année
c'était l'année d'ailleurs bien d'accord
parfait alors d'abord il ya juste un
défaut à ce qu'ils achètent au perso
c'est que c'est très long c'est que ça
dure longtemps tout l'après midi
ta femme est en faite et refaite c'est
un défaut ce pour une qualité c'est que
comme ça il ya plein d'enfants qui
interviennent et moi ce que j'ai senti
c'est une implication assez incroyable
de des enfants parce que moi je crois
que le thème l'an dernier c'était la
laïcité je crois tout à fait aller alors
ce qui est frappant c'est le sait la de
la différence des formes emprunté par
les enfants en a qui font des poèmes y
en a qui font du théâtre il y en a qui
parlent en créole en français les deux
mélangés fin voilà il ya chacun
s'approprie à sa manière le message qui
veut délivrer on sent poindre déjà les
futurs avocats les futurs politiciens
les futurs en ce sens qu'il ya des cas
des cas des talents cachés
on sent aussi qu'un acquis à moi moi ce
que j'ai senti aussi sur un 1 ou 2 1 ou
2 enfants c'est quand il y en a que ça
désinhibe esther enchantée qui en avait
qui étaient réservés hélas il était sur
des groupes de deux ou trois par par
exemple et on sentait qu'ils et les
autres faisait locomotive
et envoyez moi je me souviens d'un tout
petit garçon on sentait qu'il devait
être assez timide dans la vie est là sur
scène il s'est emparé de la scène et je
pense que c'est le type d'opération qui
fait qui fait grandir qui fait grandir
les enfants sans même qu'ils s'en
rendent compte quoi c'est le but
dominique fruteau rased juste de
désinhiber des jeunes de leur permettre
de s'exprimer de passer de l'autre côté
de la barrière succubus primaire ainsi
oui de lewy tout à fait qu'ils prennent
confiance en eux justement et puis aussi
il ya un phénomène important c'est que
ils apprennent à parler d'eux est
obligatoirement quel que soit le thème
chaque année on change de thème change
valeurs et à chaque fois il arrive à
parler d'eux mêmes
donc ils ont envie de s'exprimer de
raconter à l'autre qu'ils sont
et ça c'est très important qu'ils
puissent parler de leurs émotions leurs
ressentis de leur vie à chaque fois nous
avons des élèves qui arrivent à nous à
nous nous y tenons à nous émouvoir
risque étonnés ils m'émeuvent à ce
qu'ils disent des choses qui sont qui
sont du domaine de l'intimé et qui font
frissonner certains secrets je me
souviens mais certains membres du jury
nous nous avons frissonner alors on a en
écoutant puisque le discours oui donne
juste un petit mot de ce qui est
important aussi c'est la qualité d'
écoute c'est à dire que ça dure
longtemps comme je lé 10 mai mais
pendant tout ce temps là il ya une
écoute assez incroyable de la part des
autres élèves qui sont là ils sont très
attentifs
il n'y a pas un bruit fin je dire ça
chahute pas beaucoup alors évidemment
ils soutiennent les petits copains de
leur propre classe et donc ça crée une
après midi d'après midi de deux scènes
compétition intellectuelle
l'écouté est vraiment ai vraiment assez
assez assez magique koala dessus alors
vous vous disais tout à l'heure
a priori il n'y a pas de problème
français ou créole c'est admis c'est ça
qu'a fait est ce que justement en
utilisant le cross certains se révèlent
c'est à dire ben ils se rendent compte
que bien après tout ils sont pas
bloquées quoi on leur permet de
s'exprimer comme ils veulent alors
l'année dernière les deux élèves qui ont
gagné et et ont fait leur discours en
créole
c'était un discours très très
personnelle comme je le disais tout à
l'heure très émouvant et les membres du
jury à l'unanimité les ont retenus comme
étant essais des élèves de 3e l'année
dernière et en plus c'était des élèves
qui avait quelques difficultés scolaires
donc en effet selon les années selon les
discours nous avons nous pouvons avoir
des élèves qui ont des facilités au
niveau de leur apprentissage
mais il arrive qu'ils aient des élèves
qui se révèle lors de ce concours qui
ont pu avoir des comportements un petit
peu difficile apprentissage un peu
compliqué et pourtant qui font un
discours qui retient l'attention
l'attention de tous et qui permette
vraiment à chacun de se sentir en effet
grandir parce qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'émotion et monsieur chassagne parler
de du public
nous avons quand même à chaque fois
entre 250 et 300 élèves qui sont dans
une salle qui s'appelle un réfectoire
donc les conditions ne sont pas
excellentes et pourtant en effet de bout
en bout
il y a du plaisir ça fédère les jeunes
ça fait ça fédère les équipes même du
collège c'est un moment important de
fait qui te fait plaisir aux 190 en son
nom de marwan troisième la gagne un
concours d'éloquence encore à oui non
mais je me retiens avait dit le mal en
difficulté mais souvent c'est le cas de
l'epa montpellier voilà nous mettre le
tsl obama est officiellement en alliant
inadapté au midi mais souvent les fera
le l'école est pas adapté pour le moment
alors dominique foot heureuse et l'année
prochaine bien sûr nos rares 55ème
édition avant noël et
était trop gaillard cette année pour
nous continue pas si sûr bon vous avez
qui fait les les jeunes fils de concours
d'éloquence
ouais c'était vraiment bien moins en
plus qui aiment beaucoup parler à l'oral
j'aime beaucoup le théâtre et tout ça
m'a vraiment plu et voilages et j'ai pu
ben déjà parlé un rang devant les autres
faire partager mon discours est est ce
que j'avais à dire d'accord elisa
quelque chose à rajouter
ben moi ce que je voulais c'était faire
partager mon discours est aussi ma
musique d'accord comment ça se passe en
moi vous écoutez un extrait c'est un
extrait vous faites à deux vous vous
répondez ou alors chacun son tour
d'accord un peu des deux baies coûté on
va en vous entendant vous êtes les
gagnants donc du concours 4ème édition
du concours d'éloquence du collège du
parc plage gens d'argent des sme pardon
aura à duparc cette marée on vous écoute
et lisa au carré je vais commencer par
vous raconter une histoire
je suis très petit et chaque fois que je
vais au collège on me le rappelle cela
me chagrine un peu et ma copine qui a le
même sentiment que moi se fait
maltraiter car elle est très
intelligente et tout le monde la traite
d'intello on se comprend et d'une roue
battons ensemble amazon ans car nous
nous estimons nous nous respectons et
nous acceptons comme nous sommes
et peu à peu toutes les deux nous avons
découvert que personne n'est parfait
nous ne sommes pas seuls vous allez me
demander comment ce estimé et bien voilà
la réponse pour s'estimer il faut
compter mais pourquoi les maths
non apprendre à compter sur soi-même à
compter sur les gens qui vous aiment
pour faire enfin partie de ceux qui sont
devenus heureux pour s'estimer il faut
comprendre comprendre une leçon presque
comprendre combien la vie peut être
belle et se mettra compté pour elle pour
ses 6000 faut écrire écrire un texte
mais pas n'importe lequel écrire son
histoire ne jamais rester dans le noir
en appliquant son écriture raconter sa
propre aventure s'accepter c'est plonger
vers sa liberté
voici un petit texte pour vous expliquer
ce qu'elle estime de soi ici ne soient
ses sept
flamme qui brille à l'intérieur de nous
lorsque nous sommes fiers de ce que l'on
fait l'estimé de soi c'est croit en sa
valeur propre à sandro boner à l'amour
et à l'amitié
les signes ne soit influence toute notre
vie nos actions nos sentiments nos
pensées s'estimer c'est prendre
conscience de son unicité s'estimer soit
c'est se faire confiance
s'aimer mais c'est aussi ne pas se
dévaloriser
tout cela est essentiel pour bien vivre
avec les autres et bien vivre sa vie
croyez en vos rêves
ils deviendront peut-être réalité croyez
en vous et ils deviendront certainement
réalité on surestime ce que l'on n'est
pas et on sous estime ce que l'on m'a
rajouté je n'en ai pas envie
mais me respecte et ça oui mais pour se
respecter il faut être bien dans sa peau
mais comment l'être
pour cela il faut être libre
d'expression avoir de l'imagination
pouvoir parler à sa façon c'est sourire
à cette jolie au quai le monde faire la
somme de sa différence et se soustraire
à ignorance pouvoir déployer ses ailes
comme une hirondelle observer le ciel au
cours de son changement sait croquer la
vie à pleines dents
bravo mesdemoiselles avons tous les cas
donc pour cette 2e concours de le
conserver c'est dangereux mais bel et
bien comme ça mais commence aprés décalé
libère on est bien là mais comment ce
bonheur et qui commence tu as quelques
monstres en voie d'être atteint si vous
moquez d'animatrice pour l'épauler pour
les matinales ou pour un séjour elles
sont là à mon avis elles sont déjà
prêtes très bien oui vous êtes organes
place d'accords et l on ressent tous les
gosses à 11 ans ok merci culture
première sur réunion 1ère
la vita soit à et la vie là-bas il ya
six ans il a occupé par ses couteaux
danyel waro un bon alors la natalité
associée daniel barrow daniel son
dernier cd il appelle le moment daniel
bonsoir mais s'il ne dépassa au jusqu à
nous asseoir un chauffeur en tous les
cas merci à david chassagne daniel et là
forcément c'est moi qui suis plus
honorer alors pourquoi donc ta vie de
l'état parce que david aime aussi dans
la musique de daniel waro david a écouté
comme moi le cd et on va en parler dans
quelques instants extrait non non non
non non mais mais mais mais mais mais ma
maman mon nom mais pas
[Musique]
moussaoui n'est pas parce qu'on compose
ils sont face à lille à ce mondial et
baba
voilà pile mis les menottes ans ryo
kilos qu'il est malade en a moins la
dame madame la télécommande sans fil est
malade au trio kg qui les mena d'un
malade dans ma vous êtes annoncé
maniaque à balma
voilà dame là
la terre la case madame là
baba même à la dame avoue c'est ça mon
flair mal le yaka m'arrive un tabac
ou google en chine la mer
[Musique]
pour la can
l'otan
[Musique]
si va suivre suleimanieh le binât 20 go
s'il arrive à suleimanieh pinailler
[Musique]
voilà donc un extrait délié l'album
danyel waro moment on a onze morceaux
voilà peu près la diversité de la 7e
étape nie que tout ça que le morceau me
troue satire reflète bien l'album alors
david villa avant de la parole daniel
était pourtant pour cause le moment bmi
cause mon nikon mon nico est aussi un
moment mon moyen résistance du monde
dedans de la manne parole me dit souvent
défaut à midi puis moment maman n'est
pas un ovni cognard ont ainsi fait joli
dit maman ça me sert d'un premier texte
premier parole famille là et mon âge
affirme un peu
et
or à thin man l enracinement et
retrouver un peu nunuche coulé à notre
manière nous est dit on peut aussi tout
le valais à monza
on en a parlé sur mon enfant en
enfantant nous enfants vieux et là que
c'est le moment pour moi l'important
disent ah ouais bon chocolat mais moins
finale inattendue n'hésite pas pour moi
spécialement marine fait année il vomit
mois de l'année mais les suivants nous
monde dessine une manne ya aussi notre
vie la manière souvent les faits avec
moi alors moment là moment-là commun
notre madame c'est madame baba l'ena
aussi un ex femme aussi al attiyah ne
repasse de sa douleur 1 madame baba tout
c'est pourtant coûté comme demba ba pas
que les parts a pas longtemps
oui mais non babar invite à mon service
kabaré en 80 dessins depuis quand depuis
81 et moi toujours nature invite à me
labadie c'est moi c'est les autres
enfants habitant tampon ça me dit de
chances aux enfants habitant donc cesser
c'est le gros mais à ce grand moment
en quoi il ya une autre vie et mon lit
et moins de 7 ans il y en a deux en
trois ans déjà et bien sûr rien pour
autant un moment culturel des moments
cérémonie c'est mon rituel un moment un
moment pour payet pour moins de 9
la demande va parle de sa taille alors
david donc vous vous l'avez écouté cet
album qu'est ce que vous en pensez
qu'est-ce que vous avez mais qu'est ce
qui vous a frappé vite commencé à livrer
aux même gecko ce cruel mais bon après
c'est un peu intimidé un peu non mais
non en fait non j'étais chez daniel
quand ça c'était mardi dernier parce
qu'il y avait une conférence de presse
et moi j'ai trouvé un daniel apaisé quoi
c'est à dire et il ya plein de gens qui
pensent que daniel waro c'est quelqu'un
qui est binaire qui n'aiment pas les
oreilles qui aiment que le créole qui
travaillait il ya toute cette image là
et on fait danyel waro évidemment ça
fait des années que c'est plus ça et
puis ça l'est de moins en moins et parce
que et on le voit dans cet album il ya
évidemment tout et en créole parce que
parce que c'est ça c'est sa longue et
puis c'est à n'y arrive pas puis ça
c'est sa langue ici son combat et en
même temps moi j'ai trouvé ça très très
apaisé parce que parce qu'il n'y a pas
de démonstration de quoi que ce soit
c'est à dire y'a pas on sait que daniel
à une des plus belles voix du monde
alors moi je le dis bien suis pas le
premier à le dire une des voix les plus
singulières du monde
ouais il pourrait pousser pour le
montrer plus là et pousse pas parce que
parce qu'il n'a pas besoin de le montrer
il a une écriture qui se suffit à
elle-même alors une un album de daniel
il faut l'écouter à peu près 50 ou 100
fois pour arriver à comprendre à peu
près la trame essentielle
après les détails viennent quand on
apprend des choses à droite à gauche sur
lui sur l'album tout ça mais moi cet
album sur tout ce qui m'a fasciné c'est
les coeurs quoi il ya de la polyphonie
et away cypher incroyable ailleurs je
crois que c'est l'album sur lesquels les
choeurs sont les plus poussées ont été
les plus travaillées et ç'a été un plan
séquence
oui mais pas seulement oui mais ça
suppose de 2 de votre part une humilité
stères de ce fait les mots sont ainsi
approchés délègue à quelqu'un qui va les
arranger en faire ce qu'il veut et puis
pas d'ailleurs c'est sur c'est afida pas
n'importe qui doivent pas n'importe qui
mais c'est ce qu'on disait la conférence
de presse des fois il faudra le fin
parce que savent les verts
ça me dit t'es qu'une proposition et moi
cet album alors évidemment il est pas il
n'est pas facile d'accès un parce que
parce que daniel sait pas c'est pas
toujours simple d'accès rythmiquement
c'est pas toujours simple quand on est
sur des rythmiques malbar forcément par
essence c'est pas simple et
mélodiquement c'est pas toujours simple
mais il ya un espèce d'apprivoisement
qui se fait au fil des écoutes et il ya
une évidence coistia ça ça coule comme
une évidence en sa force ruines
il ne force pas personne ne force tout
est dans le naturel voilà ces procès
grande merci merci de dire ça coûte 10
parce que moi là bas pas osé dire que
daniel pour moi ça disent que la beauty
et les vrais les apaiser parce que nina
la cassure en ce qu'ils avaient avant
que drogba était traditionnel setra las
lenas de recherche de dents dans la
polyphonie dedans moi comme les coûts de
sa non madame l'acteur grande écoute à
moi écouter le morceau i wanna be your
man aux divers vridi montaut c'est comme
ça c'est son voie après et l'apaisé oui
sciemment 62 ans il vient view vient
vivier même et
et s'il fait manière mais pas d'un
vérité hélas 20 ans voilà mais d'un
autre vérité monde en pleine vérité on
est plein et se vouent ses amis mi
mollet content que nous livrons pas trop
à quoi aussi pour pierre mazeaud bras
kouassi qu on a 20 ans à quoi si ou lé
un grand soir et un grand drapeau et
après je me dis oh comprendre comment
nous les fait comment nous détailler
comment nous les couillons comme on ne
les voit là et nous donne lydienne bon
guide souvent des fois une bonne grand
causeur et finissent à la famille
d'aller voir la tension toujours pas en
carbone grand coup d'oeil que joli joli
joli ce principe mais quand cause du
diffuseur voilà dans la preuve qu'on
vous ait du plaisir dans la pratique
après il vous pareil vaut pas grand
chose donc ou apprendre ou apprendre
comment connaître domine comme en iran
ou même comment voulez que ça ou de
forces que ses faiblesses et que ça
déchire dans le péché de rien et on dit
bon niveau micro mme la vie faut me
chante faux mi-temps sous moi c'est sami
yen
il faut arriver c'est parce que
peut-être comme uno tout ne restent plus
longtemps
voilà et pas besoin d il faut dégonfler
vous faut pas dramatiser vous pas trop
fait confiance la vie il faut que cette
a8 imagination pour bédié c'est à
l'humilité dia bondier mètres de là mais
mon dieu c'est à l'humilité début de la
sagesse à david oui oui mais enfin moi
je crois que dans l'histoire de daniel
il ya eu une cassure une cassure qui qui
qui date du début des années 80 cirques
jusque jusqu'aux années 80 daniel est
dans une fin moi je trouve être dans une
démarche qui est très politisée c4 bien
sûr proche du pcr pour l'autonomie tout
ça et puis quand le pcr abandonne ce mot
d'ordre d'autonomie
c'est là que votre chemin commence à
changer en vous disant bon mais mes
envies de grand soir elles n'arriveront
pas ne se passera pas ça on sera pas
autonome et alors maintenant on y
revient sous d'autres formes à
l'autonomie mais et donc vous avez
changé votre combat pour pour travailler
sur le sur le fond sur la culture sur la
langue puisque la langue ses fins on a
senti essais et forcément ça devenait
plus apaisé ses terres que on n'était
plus là pour changer le monde parce
qu'on comprendrait qui changerait pas
radicalement on était là pour
accompagner les gens
vers où vraiment eu sur ce que vous êtes
sur ce qu'on est sur le rapport à
l'autre sur le rapport à soi même
le rapport aux dieux le rapport à la
liberté être à l identité même essakane
sa canne fait son chemin les b a été
construit sur 60 60
et parce que mes nuits à bien la
politique
labonal le banc guy jackman y voit bien
le résultat
le bang il à la partie à droite à gauche
entraver la fed stratégie tic tac
politique pour gagner pour eux à court
terme les élections et même mon grand
grand camarade paul vergès a fait ça
défunt respect sont là monde il compte
mais et que ça n'affecte de mon dos me
suivent le feuilleton de me suivre le
maximum d'hommes unis suivent le lebon
cause elle animera café de votre pote
domoun i suiv
elle marine que djibo malheureux la base
à dubaï li na lui soit un phrasé les
vrais et puis comme une voix de paul il
finit met donc les insupportable
d'entendre un book movie travail qui
demande c'est quoi la liberté qu'ils
aient réagi mais suivent pas marqué loin
grand macroule à la dénouer la diane ou
un phrasé un vérité puis unis suivent
ali et parce que et moyenne pas moins de
1000 votes pour des marques comme ça et
parce que et m'ont entendu en 94 quand
maria un coup de pied avec brasier
2010la dit comme ça dit daniel ou pas où
le parti jouer pour le pen communiste a
pas une parole comme ça vingt ans après
le même creusement vingt ans après
constat le monde l'a compris compatit
manifester leur ai pas dit daniel pauvre
pâtit la raison le pâtissier pour madame
le pen mais nous lui fouquet mais je
voulais pas qu'on vous dit où là où le
vraiment zéro donc le koweït oman
phrases comme zola audibert mais quelle
des granulés quel degré de conscience
politique maintenant nous lapointe
conscience politique
nou lé là pour que tout de suite et même
y répondent a noué en avaient ils payent
un coup il veut donner un morceau qui
ont grillé un bruce est un héros mini
suivent les malheureux dit ça de chez
nous tenue pays en mêlée comme ça nous
les comme ça nous les comme ça nous ne
réfléchit pas l'on ne réfléchisse pas
loin et il fait vote à nos points ouais
ouais forme comme ça et moi me dit
domine attention il faut une il faut ni
votre compte femmes la culture première
sur réunion 1ère
[Musique]
sylvain chevassus va supprimer alvin
heigl vanger siva sivasankaran y elvin
hayes et de le vendre au moulin du gua
bouyer suivent à suleimanieh levine a
été levée il n'a pris le nom moulin
gabriel méga du mungo
s'il arrive à suleimanieh binhai et
[Musique]
richard hicham olemps abriel mon cas
avec mon corps obinna jaeger le 20 août
mon gagner avec mon corps
[Musique]
finalement non
gratin
m mango vignes
à abriel et sa grâce au temps dit
[Musique]
alors l'objet de questions vous pose un
homme est alors répondent pas trop non
parce que c'est oui alors je suppose que
ce bouclier sur la photo la wii s'il
faut tuer les boers grand jeune gabriel
accident comme nous et puis arriva les
pluies depuis avant un débat sont des
coûts de sec que l'egypte va grimper de
chemin et d'un gardien basque cab à la
brutalité gars étaient là avant nous
nous l'arrivée après une passe quoi que
le tsl est au dessus de la mêlée depuis
longtemps comme beaucoup de mini naggar
des cabris nos gardiens mais à lille un
gardien mais tous les yeux avec son bel
dans la savane danois et l'issue est son
bébé après les choses allaient les
médecins sont saisis et puis il y trouva
all-in à turin priem alba avec celui ci
commence par silva silva était tout le
temps comme ça qui arrive en boutique ou
2 sec et il arriva silva silva
supplément ya besoin de commencer le
diffon de ça et après le parlement c'est
comme ça le parole après et l'amène à
moins celle de l'aiea le lièvre le
morceau vous dit gabriel résistance
gabriel st vitesse et notre vitesse
il n'est pas dans la course et jordi
société cours élite hommes à zinal il
tombe par reconnu mais moins ils
intéressent à moi que ça n'a d'ailleurs
le monde n'est pas les parents n'ont
reconnu dans la nomme les par l'apathie
l'école de faire la parade cela ne
corresponde pas rien dit
comment l'insignifiant les gabriel est
libre et portant des lunettes et ses
saillies intéressement lundi d'en tisser
un moune crac et derrière tout ça qu'ils
disent wade idy non l'apaei 10 et à
moins que ça me pense même que samir
sens commun à gabriel à côté - daniel la
religion mal bol important pour la
région mal balala la religion la culture
mme al balah toujours accompagnement
depuis - ti baba des tamouls
mapa des tamouls oui mme alleva tamouls
va pas après le mot le mot mais les
vrais nids dit mme albanel a dit mme
albanel malbar bang theory trois mâts de
marine qui suit mme soucy et cela même
quand tu domines jaoul il faut pas à les
garder sur l'a4 connaître si on regarde
pas ça tient parfois étonnants bon tout
ça trappe la ddcs en cause ces deux ci
dessus malbar sap a bondi et sa faune sa
célèbre mr raison mais du comment une
affaire comme ça et tombeaux et bâtir à
la main le choléra la main comment
comment mieux faire manger comment
peut-elle mon oreille peut être commis
que bush menée devant tout ça tout ça le
dr tout ça coulait le son la musique
mais voilà ça me nourrit et que ça et me
fais pas un compte du cas tant que
commis trop maloya maloya ramène tout
cela il refait montrent tout cela est
vraiment de dungu ding ding ding
s'attend au bois est depuis tombé
teesside en moins 1m unis veulent il
veut pas les dents - c'est sami saïdi
domine nous les nourrit comme c'est
souvent le cas c'est un sésame en
battant cité et c'est tout ça il faut
pas mettre le frein de s'en tenir aux
150 ans neveu ne veut pas nous les tout
ça en même temps nous les appels nous
les églises nous les mosquées nous est
tous en même temps
mémé dans le corps même c'est même pas
n'est pas intellectuel ça c'est mon ami
mais autant tambouille ferment mais il
permet en même temps mais les passages
grave pas grave
au contraire des sixièmes en émail jeune
fille ou à 12 matches la braise et 6 you
met en terre à l'eau ou l'envi good ça
où il a voté la goutte et oui elle me
donne les moyens d un peu vieux mais il
me l'a goûté et aimé goûter et me
partager et voilà me connais ta longue
balle tamure mieux apprendre que johnny
ville elle s appelle la mise et
l'important pour moi il fait partie de
moi comment nourrir des mandats n'est
gagné daniel c'est un combat politique à
koba culturel au combat culturel dans la
religion de faire tout ça il fait à -
pourquoi la rencontre s'est avérée la
fête témoignage a fait la file rencontre
maloya met tout de suite à faire aux
rencontres manquera tout mon pays
tout cela est ma part en daim affaires
intellectuelle seulement monde
intellectuel bien j'aime partie l'école
musical français me connaît l'ambition
de mener actuellement la dialectique
comédie mais seulement et sakhir à la
moindre attaque de money vivent là mais
quasiment à l'humidité des mines pauvres
vivent côté monaco mise mais sa part
étant distant mon bras croisés et
féminin intellectuelle dit au tibet à
quoi je m'adonne febiac aussi à quoi ça
nous on a croisé à dire en donnerons et
il m'a dit partager et ayant tous
effectivement un ensemble mais c'est
intéressant maintenant la donne avant
gbagbo n'a pas dit aux la france remonte
à l'eau à la ville au jazzman moisi
nation qui s'abat moquer gentiment dans
un livre pourquoi tout particulier aux
sentiments sont vivants a dit qu'il y
ait honte en me demandant un niveau
auprès de particuliers somme immobilier
la vie de terrebonne management humain
dans un miroir aux particuliers
[Musique]
18h50 l'invité ce soir de culture
première est aussi danyel waro daniel
dory lé pourtant ce n'est qu'en 1986 à
midi puis aux questions là parce que le
texte
les écrits en français oui enfin en
créole traduit en français traduit en
anglais
oui pourquoi l'ana tout mon soûl et
radio de ce moment les traduit en
français oui donc encore en anglais et
noah pour trois morceaux
baba adoré mon 9 à 3,3 chanson était
différent nous a fait quand même une
telle approche en anglais mais saint
magne a aussi rouvert dans le banc
public comme la partie chantée pour mes
débuts en france
dans mon idée mais explique un type et
en français non la réunion mais
l'histoire marié et ce mode moon
apprécié demande demande daniel qu il
nous a autant mais c'est ce que l'on vit
la ville a présenté le besoin présenté
il l'envié aussi le pas mon cas - et
phénomène traduction depuis bois rouge
noir ou traduction en français et en d
adam foote a fondu à 98,7 jeanne mas fès
4 à 19 ans soit 6,9 des traductions
indiqué que ça il veut dire le mot
journal mal à en créant en français et
là je dis en 2006 notre adultes et trois
mentions en français
non ne dépasse pas le français l'anglais
et oyonnax traduit
tellement naïve et les a traduits en
anglais une intervention comme ce à
l'infini traduit en allemand anglais
français les par les panais fleuri à
l'alena trois photos la madame baba delà
donc abriel canal à part
et puis c'est quoi ça s'appelle à
reynosa sa photo la réunion déjà sa
photo thierry moreau photos paysages
lille et accorde aux mets un peu elle
peut être un peu universel aussi parce
que pour moi il faut miser pas la
réunion il faut noter le qualité photo
et territoires où la foule est mon
portrait des âmes à 12h02 - je vois des
fois l'impression à tous années m'a dit
de me connaissent du coup depuis ticks
et comme comme longtemps et rien à celle
album pour mon faute est grave au noir
ou métis mathis gramoune dans tous les
sens dans l'âge dans le corps il
commençait vieillevoye ou vicente
boulons et la tête
comment ce petit robot donc mais alors
dans un texte lu voulez lire un bouquin
pas tout parce que bondé
il fait comme un bruit pendant 11
minutes où les tout seul à chanter a
capella quand même par m oui normalement
tous a dit ce matin
oui d'accord début au début c'est où
voilà madame c'est la peau collègues de
fait pour floch de boire fait cool qui
boudent les danses de bal qui n'ont pas
pris la forme pour cophan sauvé file ils
à vivre ou taupe élevé flou vivez
d'odontol en bas oui flou n'est pas ton
si ça pour ça oui mais nous aimons
madame duflot voilà des machines cette
chanson d'amour pour les ja c'est notre
chanson là moi aussi mais c'est les
écrits 101 que ça a même écrit le
premier le bishop le premier morceau à
moins qu'apple karen et puis la fonte
est carrément fondé le parti à lille a
écrit ailish entre le même lit on me l'a
proposé le carême il y avait envie de
répondre à main et son quart à marie
c'est quand même par rapport à son
démarrage la féminité de 20 me donne un
très bon dié commun comme on dit ouah ça
et il ya des crises à soumagne elle est
bâtie loin n'est pas si loin de son
ordination creusement si vous à moi me
chante le premier midi midi le carême
comme ça il est déjà midi et deux heures
le car un poco fini le match on fait
pour coiffer le font pourquoi fais-tu
être fait la peau car même pourquoi me
lève de faits commis ti croc matin fois
les tas de bois le tonnage de bois et
mon désir monte même en deuxième monte
pour mon madame on désire voilà et il
faut parce qu'à 20 mois là mes amis et
des cris ça mais décrit le sentiment
comme ça où les houles et en manque ou
les olé olé agen où il est en manque
l'amour en manque de désir ou un moment
pas désir ou le mans que
voilà la manque la voilà donc le soin
manque l'amour est mis dès midi samedi
dans madame voilà ce morceau il est
assez stupéfiant parce que d'abord enfin
moi je trouve que ça c'est une vraie
marque de la liberté danyel waro qu'on
se permet de faire un morceau de 11
minutes sans un instrument je vois sur
un album c'est déjà parce qu'on est
vraiment libre de faire ce qu'on veut
c'est cela l'artiste ha ouais non mais
oui mais c'est l'artiste qui a quand
même le choix de faire ce qu'il veut sur
ces dix quoi c'est pas tout mais c'est
vrai il fait ce qu'il veut
philippe conrath à son affaire je pense
pas qu'on pourrait le forcer à faire
grand chose et qui voudrait on apprend
aussi de nommer la partie chantée par
pas par votre mandat mais c'est
magnifique fin juillet grâce à une voix
une voix magnifique
en plus il ya un timbre enfin c'est très
profond voilà et des mois pour moi tous
disent qu'il ya un espace de liberté
permanence sur la forme et sur les
longueurs des morceaux sur les 1 sur les
arrangements ya pas il n'y a pas de
forme préétablie
on sent qu'on envoie ont commencé puis
après on les morceaux prennent une sorte
de rythme de croisière une pique parfois
la croisière s'interrompt pour changer
complètement la structure cap mais allah
allah salam al hamili secondes ça change
et c'est impeccable quand les
percussions sont impeccables fin
évidemment il joue avec des tueurs comme
on dit non non lieu avec les meilleurs
mais mais voilà il ya cette espèce de
deux prises de risques permanente face
ce qui devrait être une prise de risques
est pour et qui pour daniel waro et pas
du tout une prise de risques parce que
ces voix là c'est juste c'est juste
presque mais quarante ans de métier
quarante deux 42 10 métier je trouve que
c'est un très mauvais termes pour des
numéros parce que je suis aperçu que son
métier il le fallait
moi c'est son plaisir ou de plaisir ma
mine mana est revenue activités
commerciales avènement d un revenu
universel comme ça m'allait librement
sans t en vas y mon affaire dont il a
toujours été libre mais moi est déjà n 1
d'un de leurs revenus et à seulement
j'avais juste un truc à dire c'est que
il parlait de 2
de tout à l'heure du combat afin de
l'identité de la liberté ce que moi je
trouve que daniel la grande importance
qui a eu daniel dedans dans l'histoire
de la reine au ces qui fait partie de
ces gens qui ont appris à la réunion a
accepté sa propre musique c'est à dire
on sait très bien le peu le syndrome de
la goyave de france il s'appliquait
aussi aux magrets à moi je me sui 1 2 de
gramoun lélé que tout le monde vous
gâter un peu parce qu'on comprenait pas
ce qu'ils disent est un chanteur
malgache et quand il est parti au japon
et quand il a commencé à tourner en on
s'est dit à la réunion la lame et
gramoun lélé ces îles et il est un
terrain c'est quelqu'un qui condamne et
daniel c'est un peu pareil daniel il
avait cette image de chanteur engagé un
peu binaire jeu comment il est parti et
où hong kong on se l'arrachent
d'ailleurs toujours dans les festivals
et on a fini par keynes
si le dehors l'acceptent en veut autant
c'est bien qu'il ya quelque chose à
chercher du coup plein de gens ont
regardé daniel d'une autre manne la
province française dit bien nul n'est
prophète en son pays est bien connu à
vendre à votre quotidien dans nos côtés
en même temps qu'on me filippi issime la
mito admis fait mon mimi c'est mon fils
a prouvé tout ça sur pas alors
absolument mais vrai nommé pour en
convaincre convaincu d'état jack est un
peu réticente au bond et connaît alors
nous écoutera pas car m non c'est pas ça
parce que les attaquants mais le manceau
a même vu passer à faire avant la vente
qui taser est ce que la pièce de
marcelino méduses de toute mon existence
qui sera joué à saint benoit au théâtre
des bambous
demain samedi le 2 mai à 20h alors allez
voir pour ben c'est céline c'est un
jeune maman d'un jeune créole du sud que
la créer une pièce baisse là où entre
deux hommes voilà et puis là le conseil
manglou qu'il a été reporté à cause de
la pluie
donc il aura lieu le vendredi 19 mai à
20 heures et après français n'oublie pas
anna claudio dans la cadre album